here is corey seeger
fly ball struck well to deep left myers
going back
at the wall he makes the catch
right in front of the wall and on the
warning track
out number two of the second inning
nicely done by will myers and left he
eyes it great concentration extends he
took away a home run right there he most
certainly took away a home run delgado
strutting his stuff out left tonight jay
cronworth leads off this second for the
padres
yeah grounds on up the middle backhand
trey turner throws over muncie
and an air means that the padres get the
first base run over the game that thing
got into the camo well so cronenworth is
at second yeah that's a product of
having two shortstops one guy who hasn't
played second in quite some time you're
in a shift the ball kind of hit right
between the two
players comes up man at third two gone
myers rolls it over down the third
baseline gonna be a tough play and no
play padres score in from third comes
cronenworth
din hit it a ton in fact because it was
hit so slowly justin turner could do
nothing with it and the padres take
advantage of a miscue in the inning for
the dodgers and take a one-nothing lead
the o2
frazier strikes out swinging on a
change-up
dropped by smith throws to first to
complete the strikeout and the inning is
over
strikes him out with a fast fall to the
bottom of the zone at 97.
now the 1-2 grisham stays put machado
strikes out and the inning is over
mueller strikes out the side in the
third one down in the top of the fourth
inning max muncie coming up for the
dodgers tuno and muncie swing sits into
the air out to deep center field trent
grisham going back he is at the wall he
will leap and he makes the catch just in
front of the fence out of the 396 marker
to the right of straight away center
field don't think he took a home run
away but it was close
and max muncie just missed a birthday
bomb that is out number two here in the
fourth
two and two coming and a swinging emmaus
blake got the fastball past him strike
three
fifth k the night for snell
and two outs that's a straight challenge
there two and two to will smith swinging
a miss now gets him again back-to-back
case to end a 1-2-3 fifth inning and
blake snell absolutely brilliant here
tonight again
against the dodgers now frazier in
scoring position nonetheless and here's
trent grisham this will get away
wild pitch gets frazier 90 feet away
three and two fraser at third here's the
pitch grisham swings hits a ground ball
off the left side of the mound funny hop
but seeger's got it it's short throw to
first high did muncie keep his foot on
the bag he did max muncie just saved an
error and a run for the dodgers nice
play over at first base fernando tatis
junior leading off bottom of the sixth
inning padres still have a one-nothing
lead on the dodgers walker bueller and
blake snell both outstanding padres have
an unearned run that's it
he struck him out back to back high hard
ones for the first out of the six
this tatis jr has struggled with his
shoulder and been on the il
it seems like his plate discipline is a
little different home one one
cronenworth lifts it to right field but
got it off the end of the bat chris
taylor is there and one two three
through the teeth of the lineup well to
be honest blake snell has not been here
many times this year talking about the
seventh inning that is but here he is
six and a third deep into this outing
and now has reached that hundred pitch
plateau
that's strike three
aj pollock with some things to say to
hiccups seven strikeouts for snell two
down two and two to secret two outs
nobody on the pitch is taken right down
the middle and at the knees strike three
call back to back strikeouts of pollock
and seeger to end a one two three
seventh inning and if that's the end of
the night for blake snell what an end it
is
seventh inning stretch at petco padres
one dodgers nothing hubert struck out
seven he's not walked anybody it's only
five hits in this game combined two for
the dodgers three for the padres another
two two as 100 picks of the night he
strikes out osmo at the curve it's eight
strikeouts for bueller two down on the
seven three two pitch
first walk of the night and that is
going to end the night of walker beulah
great game pitch by walker mueller
dodgers will try to get him off of the
hook blake smell for the first time
since july of 2018
is pitching in the eighth inning
and a swing and a miss he strikes out
taylor three strikeouts in a row nine
and all for style he's matched his
career long seven and a third
smith hits a fly ball deep left field
this game is tied
will smith saves the day and he does it
again in a high fastball it's 122.
swinging a miss and he strikes out cody
bellinger it's ten strikeouts for blake
snell two down in the eighth 122 pitches
tonight for blake snell career high
seven and two thirds of career high
padres fans will let him know what they
think of him as he comes off
so it's up to nola or this thing is
going into overtime
breaking ball call strike three and that
was a beauty and that's number one
thousand for kenley janssen 1 000
strikeouts in his brilliant dodger
career 2-1 pitch is right back up the
middle but it'll be frazier behind the
bag second his throw to first is in time
and some well-positioned defense takes
care of the top of the 10th inning for
the padres the dodgers cannot get the
automatic runner home pollock is left at
third we'll go to the bottom of the 10th
inning so frazier pops out two down
runners on the corners
he struck him out
alex vasya does it again
look at him roar oh he's abused no no
joe trying to walk it off in san diego
tonight winning run at third base in
caratini the 1-2
he strikes him out right down the middle
and will play the 12th this is ordered
to run in the 12th
3-2 here's the pitch and it is swung on
and sky to left field should be routine
tommy pham over into the gap he will
make the catch and the dodgers leave
them loaded in the top of the 12th
inning he's not a strike away from
getting out of this
swinging a miss and he does get out of
it we're going to the bottom of the 13th
in san diego and the dodgers leave two
more on base so in the pitcher's spot
it's spinning mckinney
mckinney with a base hit into center
does it taylor's in the score sweet
mercy 2-1 in the 15th first and third
for trey turner and he grounds running
left field the floodgates have opened
smith in
and now carratini at third base with one
out and fernando at the plate fly ball
deep right field off the bat at fernando
that ball is back and it is
gone fernando tati's junior is tied to
score in the bottom of the 15th inning
el nino
unbelievable
that'll make you forget about your own
for
six hammers the ball deep center field
forget about it gone
two run blasts
badgers back in front
time run at the plate two gone 16th
inning and a 2-2 pitch from shane greene
is hitting the ground left side backhand
seeger
that does it
what a night
what a ride in a 5-3 win for the dodgers
in
innings